Donald Trump has reportedly rejected an
intelligence report on his majority
Muslim nation immigration band basically
because it just didn't go along with
what he thought which is that it'll
improve national security which we all
knew was actually not going to happen
compiled by the Department of Homeland
Security this report given to the Trump
White House said that if you ban all of
the citizens of seven predominantly
Muslim countries from coming to the
United States that it's not an effective
way of stopping terrorists from coming
to the US because quote the country of
citizenship of an individual is unlikely
to be a reliable indicator of potential
terrorist activity well yeah this report
given to the Trump White House found
that in the last six years foreign-born
US residents who were inspired to
participate in terror acts had actually
come from 26 different countries however
only two of those countries Iraq and
Somalia are among the top 10 origin
countries for foreign-born individuals
engaged engaged in terror and there have
been zero successful terror attacks
perpetrated by citizens of any country
on the list on us soil since nine eleven
and of course most of the nine eleven
terrorists from Saudi Arabia which isn't
on the list at all also the report found
that more than half of the 82 people
quote primarily based in the United
States who had been killed while
engaging in acts of terrorism were born
in the United States of America these
are facts I've been talking about them
for a long time the trumpets don't seem
to want to hear it so how did the White
House and Trump respond to this report I
don't think you'll be shocked to hear
that they dismiss the entire thing as
poorly researched and politically
motivated a senior administration
official said quote the president asked
for an intelligence assessment this is
not the intelligence assessment that the
president asked for that's a CEO answer
pad which is if you're a CEO and you get
data that doesn't confirm your
preconceived notions you ask someone to
change the data to reflect your reality
and that's what Trump wants here he
wants reports that reflect his political
reality which is not
reality as we know it I mean I think
it's fair to say that Trump and company
people in his administration like Steve
Bannon and Steven Miller yeah are layman
on the topic of national security so you
think they would just kind of defer to
people in the intelligence community and
you people in their own you forget what
they also wouldn't be on the National
Security Council rewrite tattoo and also
the first of people in their own
Department of Homeland Security bless
this is never about keeping Americans
safe this is about fulfilling a campaign
promise and at the core I mean it's
pretty xenophobic it's almost like Trump
is clueless and unqualified to be
President if only we had had national
debates that might have helped us figure
that out i don't know that would have
been useful every time I hear that
Donald Trump opined about something in a
way that makes him sound completely
clueless I'm reminded that he's the same
guy who said this just a few days ago
this is my new go-to you know what
uranium is right Singh called nuclear
weapons and other things like lots of
things are done with uranium including
some bad things yeah do you know what my
favorite part about that is he's kind of
being patronizing when he says it yeah
he's like educating someone i'll write
what uranium is yelling fake news at CNN
when you don't like what they say is bad
yelling fake at intelligence agencies
when people's lives depend on their work
is worse than bad a more general
headline for this story would be Trump
rejects anything that doesn't
corroborate what he already believes to
be true and that's incredibly scary for
a president to be doing today's show is
brought to you by godaddy where you can
buy your own domain name build a website
or use any of Go Daddy's business tools
you can save thirty percent at try
godaddy.com slash david go daddy has
actually been the official host of the
david pakman show website for many many
many years the 24 7 customer support has
been a very good thing for us I've
called them at really odd times when
we've had website issues and they are
always available they are the largest
domain registrar and whether you have a
new idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to godaddy they can do it all 13 million
customers try it and get thirty percent
off at try godaddy.com slash david